[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute eine
grill beilage ich liebe eigentlich am
grill immer nur den tisch mit den
beilagen und ich habe mir ganz viel
vorgenommen ich möchte euch ganz viele
tipps zeigen und auch salate aber auch
so brot bei land und damit starte ich
heute ihr könnt aber auch jetzt schon in
die kommentare schreiben was ist eure
liebste grill beilage und wenn ich da
was drin leser was ich so noch nicht
gemacht habe dann sind ich euch das
gerne hier auf einem kanal zeigen ich
habe jetzt hier mail und gebt da direkt
trocken hier für mich dazu fusioniert
natürlich auch mit frischhefe die hätte
ich jetzt gar nicht da wenn ihr frische
hefe verwendet dann einfach in lauwarme
milch auflösen mit dem zucker aber das
funktioniert auch ganz gut die ganzen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer unten in die video beschreibung
und ich hier mache ich jetzt so eine
kleine kugel
wobei ich könnte eigentlich schon seit
mit dazugeben
grob verrühren und in die kuhle kommen
jetzt meine flüssigen zutaten da habe
ich milch wasser und sonnenblumenöl und
das geht ja auch jetzt flüssige zutat
ich habe hier ein ei und brauchte zum
verstreichen das geld und daher um das
eiweiß jetzt irgendwie zu verwerten gebe
ich das gleich auch noch dazu und dann
wird alles miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
ich habe den tag jetzt auf der
arbeitsfläche noch fünf bis sechs
minuten lange knete dann werdet ihr auch
merken dass der immer geschmeidiger wird
und jetzt einfach zu einer kugel formen
und dann kommt der teig zurück in die
schüssel ihr könnt da auch gerne noch
mal ein bisschen fett übergehen würde
ich jetzt nicht nehmen damit nicht zu
trocken wird also einfach nochmal mit öl
benetzen sich mit sie einfach auf diesen
sehr lecker und dann bedecken also
abdecken oben und dann müsste in 45
minuten lang gehen lassen oder es gibt
auch ein trick da könnt ihr einfach im
backofen auf 30 grad vorheizen bei
manchen backöfen geht das andere haben
nur 50 grad als mindest ein
stellungnahme könnte auf 50 grad
vorheizen wieder ausmachen zehn minuten
warten dann ist es ungefähr bei 30 grad
und dann braucht der teig nur so
ungefähr 25 minuten zu gehen aber wir
machen in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
kräuterbutter bis gleich
[Musik]
so führen soll kräuterbutter brauchen
wir natürlich
mehr und butter für unsere kräuterbutter
brauchen natürlich brutal und das
wichtigste ist dass ihr sie früh genug
aus dem kühlschrank nimmt weil die muss
richtig schön weich sein damit wir sie
gleich verdrücken können und matschen
können es hat mir jetzt gerade noch
spontan überlegt als ich noch mal die
kräuter geholt habe wieso tut man nicht
einfach mit rein die sind nicht nur
hübsch die roten ziemlich sondern
schmecken auch gut also werde ich dir
jetzt auch noch fein würfeln und zeigt
euch dann was in meinem kräuterbutter
reinkommt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt zur butter knoblauch
gegeben ganz ganz wichtig für den club
auch immer dazu gesalzen habe ich schon
noch nicht könnt ihr euch entscheiden
nehmt ihr café de paris das ist auch
eine kräuter gewürze mischung die ist
mega lecker hier ist natürlich auch
knoblauch drin und zwiebeln und
petersilie richtig genial oder nimmt ihr
ganz klassisch italienische kräuter da
nehme ich jetzt viva italia da ist auch
oregano rosmarin bohnenkraut majoran als
ist auch eine super leckere mischung und
klassischer sind italienische kräuter
aber auch richtig lecker findet café de
paris aber ich mache es heute so dass
ich die italienischen kräutern nehme und
da kommt jetzt eigentlich gar nichts
mehr dazu tatsache das war es schon und
die roten ziegeln die kommen gleich
wieder zum einsatz daher habe ich jetzt
bei weiter geschoben und hier nehme ich
mir einfach mit gabel und zerstampft
dass du ein bisschen damit sich das
verbindet
[Musik]
so die wartezeit ist und wir können
endlich weiter machen eigentlich ist das
ein super entspanntes rezept also
zwischendurch kann man die küche
aufräumen ein bisschen chillen und den
teig werde ich jetzt einfach austreiben
ich habe jetzt hier mein teil crawler
eingestellt auf 6 millimeter einfach so
zur orientierung für euch und dann vom
der am besten ein rechteck oder auch
quadrat ich werde gleich sehen es sieht
am ende sowieso zerschnitten und dann
kommt auch schon unsere kräuterbutter
drauf
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt hier mal abgelesen 40
x 30 cm einfach für euch zur
orientierung aber wenn diese ungefähr
sechs millimeter dick macht dann finde
ich es eine super dickes ist nicht zu
dick und ich zu dünn und ihr könnt halt
ganz viele tote aneinanderreihen und
jetzt nehme und wie gesagt unsere
kräuterbutter und verstreichen lassen
könnt ihr euch entweder ein messer oder
linke toilette nehmen und das ist immer
so der schönste bart finde ich liebe das
vieh auf seiner leinwand zu zeichnen und
er hat recht so gut und ich mache es so
dass ich die roten zwiebeln dann
anschließend darauf verteilen und so ein
bisschen an drücke damit die mir auch
nicht runterfallen und dann schneidet
ihr das ganze schon in rechtecke schaut
euch einfach an wie groß ihre kasten
formen ist und es muss aber auch nicht
perfekt sein es wird am ende sowieso gut
aussehen und dann rein wir das an ganz
wichtig noch zusagen auf meiner silikon
back matte bitte nicht schneiden mit
einem messer ich habe zehn marzipan
messer oder ihr nehmt den rücken von
einem buttermesser also wirklich ganz
vorsichtig damit ihr euch nicht
zerschneidet
[Musik]
das ist das zwischenergebnis bin so froh
dass ich die roten zwiebeln auch mit
reingenommen habe ich diesen so gut aus
da drin und die geben natürlich auch
nochmal geschmack ab das ganze jetzt
noch mal gehen lassen damit es noch mal
aufgeht und richtig fluffig wird und am
besten einfach ein tuch darüber lägen
damit ja auch nicht austrocknet und in
der zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal das
übrig gebliebene eigelb mit einem
schluck milch verquirlen
so nachdem wir dann das alpha quält habt
könnt ihr die oberfläche damit nämlich
richtig schön bestreichen bevor es in
den backofen kommt weil das auge isst
mit und das macht das brot noch mal
richtig schön goldbraun auch von oben
und ansonsten backt ihr das dann einfach
nur noch bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze dieses gold braunes und
könnte dann praktisch schon genießen
[Musik]
so ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß
zum nachbacken lasst es euch schmecken
es ist so so so gut es schmeckt war es
schmeckt aber auch kalte können sie auch
aufwärmen wir können auch am nächsten
tag essen aber ein zeige ich euch bei
eurem grillabend wird das gros der s6
sein das garantiere ich euch also ganz
viel spaß damit abonniert meinen kanal
wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan
habe und dann freue ich mich von euch
unten in den kommentaren zu lesen dass
es gerne austauschen was ich noch so für
grill bei langen rezepte machen soll und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
rezept
[Musik]